the next apex legends event is called
the old ways and it's all about
bloodhound here's everything you need to
know about what the hunter is bringing
to the battle royale the old ways is the
fourth event to feature a town takeover
this latest takeover bloodhounds trials
adds a prowler enclosure to the
northwest part of world's edge it's a
dangerous place to drop but you'll find
high tier loot there if you manage to
beat the beasties respawn has also
hinted that there could be some juicy
bits of lore to and cover there too and
what's an apex legends event without
prizes completing event challenges will
net you all sorts of special cosmetics
including the Youngblood skin for
bloodhound you can see them wearing it
and responds latest animated short
bloodhound was the focus of season One's
legendary Hunt event - and if you missed
out on any of those previous cosmetic
rewards good news they're back for the
old ways greats voices of the past skin
and the Arthur Irwin's trophy collector
skin also get recolored versions the old
ways runs from April 7th through the
21st but that's not the only change
you'll see when you log in he pecks
legends is also adding a permanent duo's
mode after appearing in the game several
times in a temporary capacity
additionally a map rotation feature is
on the way which will allow you to
choose whether you want to drop on to
world's edge or Kings Canyon more
choices and how you want to play is
never a bad thing so to keep up with all
the changes in Apex legends and other
battle Royales like it stick with the
game spot squad